ذكرت وسائل اعلام امريكيه واسرائيليه ان
وفدا رفيع المستوى من اسرائيل سيزور
واشنطن الاسبوع المقبل لاجراء مباحثات مع
مسؤولين بينهم مستشار الامن القومي ومن
المقرر ان تتطرق المباحثات التي تاتي بعد
اتفاق ايراني الامريكي انتقدته اسرائيل
الى عدد من القضايا من بينها امكانيه قيام
تحالف دفاعي امريكي اسرائيلي والموقف من
ايران
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله توقيت زياره
الوفد الاسرائيلي الى واشنطن وما اهداف
هذه الزياره التي تاتي في اجواء اتفاق
امريكي ايراني والتوتر على الحدود
اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه كيف ستتعامل واشنطن
مع ضغوط تل ابيب المتزايده لمنحها دعما في
مجلس الامن بشان مهمه اليونيفال على
حضورها مع لبنان وتحذيرها من تفاهمات اوسع
بين واشنطن وطهران ما رؤيه واشنطن لامن
المنطقه وملفاته الملحه وما مدى تقاربها
مع رؤيه تل ابيب في هذا الصدد خاصه في ضوء
اجتماع العلمين التنسيقي بين الاردن ومصر
والسلطه الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه ايضا من واشنطن السيد ديفيد وهو
المستشار السابق لشؤون الامن القومي
الامريكي ومن الناصره السيد ايهاب جبارين
المحلل السياسي والباحث المتخصص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه مرحبا بكم جميعا دكتور خليل
ماذا تقرا في توقيت هذه الزياره للوفد
الاسرائيلي الى واشنطن
هذا ياتي في اطار التنسيق المستمر بين
دولتين حريفيتين حريفيتا
اشتراكه كبيره جدا وهي امريكا واسرائيل
ولكن ايضا في اطار مهم جدا من حيث التوقيت
نحن نتحدث عن اولا ما تم انجازه مؤخرا
باتفاق ما بين امريكا وايران فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه الافراج عن خمسه سجناء امريكيين
الاصول ايرانيه تحتجزهم ايران مقابل
الافراج عن حوالي 6 مليار دولار تمثل يعني
رات تنفس لايران فيما يتعلق بموجات ازمه
الاقتصاديه المتفاقمه عندها هناك مخصص
الاموال فيما يتعلق بما تسميه اسرائيل دعم
انشطه الحركه المقاومه الفلسطينيه وكذلك
حزب الله وبالتالي هناك مخاوف اسرائيليه
تستخدم هذه الاموال في اطار هذا الموضوع
الامر اخر متعلق بما يجري الحديث عنه في
امكانيه توصل اتفاق ولو جزئي بين ايران
وبين امريكا فيما يتعلق بالملف النووي
الايراني خاصه في ظل الحديث مؤخرا حول
قيام ايران بتخفيف او تقليل سرعه ما يتعلق
بتقسيم وبالتالي هناك امكانيه لوصول
الاتفاق ولو جزئي يمثل نوع من الانجاز
اداره باي بالتناكه مخوف اسرائيليه من ان
يكون هذا الامر على وشك الحدوث هناك حاله
خوف سهيل متواصله بما يتعلق بالتواصل
الاتفاق بين طرفين الايراني والامريكي
وبالتالي محاوله تعطيل او تخريب اي اتفاق
هو يعتبر هدف اسرائيلي مهم الامر الاخر
ايضا متعلق في رايي الشخصي بالدافع باتجاه
التطبيع بين الدول العربيه خاصه في الحديث
حول امكانيه وجود طبيعه السعوديه وبين
اسرائيل قبل نهايه العام الحالي موجود ضعف
ضعف والدفع من اداره بايرن بهذا الاطار
خاصه في ظل محاوله بايدن تصوير الامر
باعتباره نصرا وانجدا سياسيا في الحمله
الانتخابيه المقبله لدى اوشكت على الدخول
في مراحلها الاولى وبالتالي هناك اهداف
كثيره جدا متعدده جزء منه متعلقه قبل قليل
بمحاوله تاطير العلاقات الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه فيما يتعلق بملفات المنطقه
العربيه او فيما يتعلق بالتعاطف مع ايران
في مرحله المقبله سيدي ايهاب اضافه الى ما
تفضل به الدكتور خليل
هذه زياره تاتي بعد التوتر سياسي غير
مسبوق ربما بين اداره رئيس امريكي وحكومه
اسرائيليه وصلت حد قول مسؤولين في حكومه
نتنياهو ان اسرائيل دوله مستقله وتاخذ
القرارات التي تناسبها بالمفهوم
الاسرائيلي ايضا ما اهميه هذه الزياره
رفيعه المستوى
وهي لم تصدر من اي شخصيات بل الحديثون عن
الذين يعني تنظر اليهم الاداره الامريكيه
تحديدا كتهديدا لمباشر لامنها القومي
فبالتالي اظن ان حده التوتر ما بين
الاداره الامريكيه الضعيفه يمكن القول في
هذه المرحله واسرائيل المنهكه هو وصل ذوته
يعني يمكن القول انه لم يكن على مثل هذه
النحو منذ على الاقل منذ اربعين او اكثر
بقليل
بكل تاريخ العلاقات الاسرائيليه الامريكيه
فبالتالي هذه النقطه الاولى ولكن على
هنالك ابعاد اخرى يعني في نهايه المطاف
بدون ادنى شك ان اسرائيل حاولت على مدى
سنوات ان تبني مسار الدبلوماسي تحالف سنه
اسرائيلي لمواجهت او بشكل ادق لتغذيه
البيران الاسرائيليه التي كانت تتغذى منها
من وجود الايراني في هذه المنطقه بالتالي
تقوم به الاداره الامريكيه في هذه المرحله
هي اصفاء نوع من الشرعيه على الوجود
الايراني في الشرق الاوسط بل يمكن القول
حتى ان ما يسمونه في داخل اسرائيل في هذه
المرحله هو نوع من التطبيع الايراني في
الشرق الاوسط فبالتالي هي لا تنظر لهذا
المسار بالنحو الجيد بل تنظر اليه بكثير
من عين الريبه وشك يعني بعيدا عن تخصيب
اليورانيوم والوصول الى قنبله نوويه وما
الى ذلك من امور والمشروع النووي الايراني
بل هي يعني هذا ما يظهر على العالم
بالخفاء هنالك تخوف بان تستغل ايران هذه
السنوات للعوده وبقوه الى وجودها وحضورها
في الشرق الاوسط عما كانت عليه في السابق
يجب ان نتذكر حتى سنوات السبعين اسرائيل
وايران كانت لديهم علاقاتهما
الممتازه في السيطره او في محاوله تجاوز
اسرائيل الدول العربيه في داخل الشرق
الاوسط عن طريق ايران مشاريع نفط كبيره
وكثيره كان هنالك الكثير من الامور التي
سئلت جيدا مدى قدره ايران وقوتها يعني اذا
استطاعت ان تتجاوز عقبه الدول العربيه
التي تجاوزتها اسرائيل فبالتالي هذا الامر
الذي لا تريده اسرائيل والاكثر من ذلك
يمكن القول ان ما يعني التحالف
تسميه التحالف الدفاعي ما بين امريكا
وتل ابيب هو عمليا محاوله لوقف رغبات
اسرائيل في ابرام تحالف عسكري مشابه سنه
اسرائيلي مع الدول العربيه ودول الخليج
لمحور التالي
السيد ديفيد اداره الرئيس بايدن التي تبدو
غير متحمسه على الاقل حتى الان للقاء
مباشر بين نتنياهو وبايدن كيف تنظر الى
اهميه زياره هذا الوفد الى واشنطن
[موسيقى]
الاداره هي ترى ان هناك حاجه لترطيب
الامور بعد سته اسابيع عندما يكون هناك
زعيمه البلدان الرئيس بايدن والرئيس
الوزراء ياهو اللذين قد يلتقي وجها رغم ان
ذلك لم يحدد بعد على مستوى الامم المتحده
لكن ما يحدث الان يقولون لهم لياتي الفريق
الاسرائيلي الى واشنطن يلتقي بجيك سولفا
في نقاش ودي مع مسؤولي وزاره الخارجيه
بالطبع ايضا بالضروره لن يكون هناك تقييم
لمجريات الامور لضمان ان الطرفين يتواصلان
فهما
حليفان هم حلفان الولايات المتحده
ان تضمن انها تفحص الموقف وتتاكد من لكي
لا يفوتنا اي شيء وايضا من خلال التوقع
والتحضيرات
هذا سؤال مهم جدا استاذ جلال واعتقد
الفتره المقبله استكشف عن الاجابه عنه لكن
بشكل عام هناك بالفعل مخاوف اسرائيليه من
ان يؤدي الاتفاق الذي حدث خلال يومين
الماضيين الى اتفاق اوسع فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه توصل كما قلت في مداخله الاولى
اتفاق جزئي ولا مؤقت حول المعرفه النووي
الايراني خاصه
وعد بشكل مباشر انه احد اهدافه الرئيسيه
والقيام بالتواصل اتفاق نووي ايراني او
حتى اعاده تحياء الاتفاق في 2015 وبالتالي
نزع فتيل الدخول في مواجهه عسكريه في
المنطقه لكن ايضا على مدار العماني ونصف
الماضيين نجحت يصل بشكل او باخر في تخريب
كل محاولات التفاوض بين الطرفين الامريكي
والايراني سواء من خلال يعني ادعاء وجود
او اقتراب ايران من حافه العتبه النوويه
او من خلال حادثه تخريب ملف المسؤول عن
هذا الملف وهو روبوت تم عزل قبل اسابيع
القليل من الامريكيه والمسؤوله عن التوصل
اتفاق مع ايران وكان يتمتع بقبول دوله لحد
بعيد الان هو معزول وبالتالي هناك يعني
وهناك مخاوف من ان يؤدي ذلك الى عدم تواصل
التفاف في المرحله المقبله الامر الاخر
ايضا متعلق بانه مخاوف من انه اي تهديد في
المنطقه العربيه او اي نوع من التهدئه
للصراعات يعني امكانيه اتحاد احداث او
قيام نوع من اعاده توازي في المنطقه
العربيه خاصه لصالح ايران لكن لديها وجود
في اكثر من دوله عربيه كما نعلم جميعا لو
بالتالي اي تهدئه
للتوترات في المنطقه لا تخدم على الاطلاق
المشروع الذي يكون بشكل بقري على فكره
الخوف او الامني الذي يستخدم داخل في اطار
الصراع الداخلي وبالتالي اعتقد حتى هذه
اللحظه هناك نوع من الجديه الامريكيه في
انهاء الاتفاق على اطلاق سراح سجناء
الامريكيين الايرانيه هناك ايضا اتفاق على
فصل ملفات وبالتالي من الصعب ان نربط
بينهم يعني بمعنى اخر هناك اكثر من ملف
ملتهب في العلاقه بين ايران وبين امريكا
مثلا الملف التواجد الايراني في سوريا وفي
العراق وكذلك في اليمن وكذلك امكانيه حدوث
اشتباكات بين قوات الامريكيه والايرانيه
في سوريا وبالتالي هناك اكثر ملف بشكل اخر
كما قلنا قبل قليل هناك بادره ايجابيه
هناك خطوه ايجابيه حدثت قبل يومين هناك
بخليا تعد هذه الخطوه الى خطوات اخرى قد
تؤدي بشكل او باخر التقويض الامن
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي دخول قد يكون في
مشكله مع المقبله وكيف ستتصرف اسرائيل في
مقابل هذه الجديه سيدي ايهاب التي تحدث
عنها دكتور خليل
هل يستطيع نتنياهو ان يترجم تحذيراته على
الارض من تقارب ايراني امريكي اوسع في
المنطقه
يعني يمكن ان نستشهد هنا بما جاء على لسان
عمص يدلين رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه
السابق بانه لا يوجد هنالك اسرائيل في هذه
الحاله قطعا هي الاكثر ضعفا لكي تحاول ان
ان تتفاوض بكل شان الملف النووي الايراني
امام الاداره الامريكيه
ولكن على الرغم من كل ذلك انا باعتقادي ان
هنالك مسار اخر يمكنه ان تتجاوزه اسرائيل
والذهاب اليه في محاوله الابتزاز الاداره
الامريكيه الضعيفه في مثل هذه المرحله
وهذا ما يعني ما تحاول التلويح اليه في
اكثر من مره هنالك ثلاثه ملفات هي تريدها
يمكن القول بكل ثمن الملف الاول بكل ما
يخص
الجبهه الشماليه والحدود اللبنانيه الملف
الثاني السعوديه بدون ادنى شك وكذلك
الاستيطان فهي بهذه الحاله اسرائيل سوف
تحاول ان تبتزر اضاءه الامريكيه في
محاولات كهذه وظلم ان هذا الامر سوف يكون
يعني هذه الثلاثه ملفات سوف تكون
حاضره جدا في خضم هذه الزياره
لمحاوله ان تتجاوز خضوعها ووضوحها لهذا
الاتفاق يعني انا يجب ان نتذكر ان اي
سيناريو وجود اتفاق عدم وجود اتفاق
يعني التخصيب اليونانيوم عدم تخصيب
اليورانيوم او او تخفيضه الى مستوى معين
كل هذه السيناريوهات لن تخرج منها اسرائيل
راضيه والاداره الامريكيه تعلم ذلك جيدا
وقطعا قطعا اداره بايدن الموجوده الان
يعني تحاول ان تلبي بضع الوعود الانتخابيه
فبالتالي سوف تحاول ان تربط ذلك بثلاثه
ملفات الاستيطان هنا يجب ان نركز عليه
وتحديدا الان في انخضام وجود هذه
الاتفاقيه اتفاقيه العلمين سوف تحاول
اسرائيل ان تحاول ان تبتز وان تقتطع اموال
لصالحها وان لنقل ان تقف سدا بوجه بضع
شروط هذه الاتفاقيه او ما يمكن ان يبعم
عنها من ناحيه ثانيه كذلك ان تعجل بكل ما
يخص عمليه الاتفاق مع السعوديه يجب ان
نتذكر ان في خطابه الاخير في الكونجرس
كانك لمح بكلمات هي اقرب الى الصلاه الى
وجود مثل هذا الاتفاقيات وهذه اللغه يعني
احد الانتقادات التي تترجم في داخل
اسرائيل ان هذه اللغه الجبناء فبالتالي
نعم واضح جدا ان هنالك الضغط وهنالك اهميه
لابرام هذا الاتفاق مع السعوديه واسرائيل
لطالما نظرت ان او قالت وصرحت ان اتفاقيه
ابرهم لن تبرم الا بوجود اتفاقيه مع
السعوديه او لا تنتهي الا بوجود اتفاقيه
مع السعوديه فبالتالي هذه الثلاث ملفات
ممكن ان تكون حاضره للابتزاز امام الاضاءه
الامريكيه السيد كيف ستنظم اداره الرئيس
بايدن هذا الخلاف مع اسرائيل والضغط
الاسرائيلي المتزايد حول تفاهم امريكي
ايراني اكبر واوسع ربما في المنطقه
الحديثه عن عن قرب لي عوده
اللقاء حول مفاوضات لبرنامج ايران النووي
ليست فقط هذه القضايا التي طرحت الان
وهناك قضايا اخرى جامعه شامله لكل هذه
الامور الا وهي العلاقه بين بنجم نتنياهو
والرئيس بايدن فهي علاقه ليست قويه هي
علاقه طويله الامد موجوده منذ مده لكن
بين الرجلين الرجل الرئيس بايدن كان دائما
قويا لاسرائيل على مدى حياته السياسيه
كلها ولكن
وهو ايضا من الداعمين الراسخين
لشعب اسرائيل وكثير من حكوماتها لكن هناك
تصدع وخلاف بين الرجلين الان وهذا ما
يضيفه الى التوترات التي وصفها ضيفاكم اذا
الرئيس بايد النفاوض جيد ولكن في خاتمه
المطاف وربما هذا ما سيحدث في شهر سبتمبر
المقبل سيكون هناك محاوله الى اعاده
الامور الى مجاريها الطبيعيه
بين الطرفين لكنني لا اتوقع حقيقه ان
تتمخض امور نهائيه عن هذه الزياره الحاليه
بين
المجموعتين الامنيتين اعتقد انهم سيدفعون
بالاتفاقات النهائيه الى ما بعد سته او
ثمانيه اسابيع هذا من جهه من اخرى البيت
الابيض سيحاول ان يركز على انه الرئيس اذا
لم يكن على وفاق مع
نتجاهل لكنه سوف يستمر بدعمه القوي لدوله
اسرائيل ولحقها في الوجود اضافه الى حق
الفلسطينيين في الوجود وان تكون لهم
القدره في الوصول الى الضفه الغربي هذه
الامور التي سيدفع باتجاهها البيت الابيض
على مدى الاشهر القادمه سيدي ايهاب في
الناصره كما اسلفنا من اهداف هذه الزياره
للوفد البحث فيما يسمى تحالف دفاعي يدفع
نتنياهو باتجاهه ما حاجه اسرائيل وحكومه
نتنياهو لهذا التحالف الدفاعي مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
يعني بطبيعه الحال العلاقات
الاسرائيليه الامريكيه هي اكبر بكثير من
علاقات بايدن وبنيامين نتنياهو اكبر بكثير
من علاقات يمكن ان تتوتر يعني بسبب
شائبه هنا او هناك بطبيعه الحال للعلاقات
فيها علاقات استراتيجيه عسكريه بعيده
الامد حتى ان كان في المسار الاقتصادي
الاستثماري في الاستثمارات العسكريه او
حتى في
القطاع الدفاعي والهجومي حتى ان صح القول
فبالتالي اظن انه يعني مثل هذه اتفاقيات
هي تاتي او مثل هذا التحالف ياتي لكي يعزز
من هذا الموقف من جهه تاكيدا على ان
التواجد الامريكي او البرامج الاتفاق
الامريكي الايراني هو ليس بمثابه تهديد
لاسرائيل بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر هذا من جهه
اولى ووجهه معينه وكذلك يجب ان نتذكر ان
في نهايه المطاف الاداره الامريكيه لم
تنظر يعني بعين الرضا الى وجود نوع من
التحالف الاسرائيلي السني في المنطقه
ولذلك هي تحاول الالتفاف عليه وبطبيعه
الحال حتى ان ارادت ان تتقدم باتفاقيه
معينه ما بين اسرائيل والسعوديه هي سوف
تحاول ان تلبي رغبات اسرائيل الدفاعيه
بطرق التفافيه اخرى تكون هي فيها حاضره
تحديدا في ظل وجود روسي صيني يهدد الوجود
الامريكي في المنطقه مؤخرا دكتور خليل في
حال حصل هذا الحلف الدفاعي الا يكبل يد
الجيش الاسرائيلي في المنطقه
لا يعني بغض النظر عن اي حديث حول تحالف
وهي بالفعل هناك علاقات استراتيجيه
امريكيه اسرائيليه قويه جدا نتكلم على
اسرائيل اكبر متلقي للدعم العسكري
الامريكي في العالم بحوالي اربعه مليار
دولار لديها اقوى نوع من الاسلحه المطوره
خاصه المصنوعه في امريكا وبالتالي هناك
بالفعل تحالف استراتيجي دفاعي وهجومي ايضا
بين طرفي لكن اعتقد انه مرحله تحديدا ما
تقوم باداره بيض المحاوله تطمين اسرائيل
براي اتفاق يحدث مع ايران لن ياتي على
حساب العلاقه الاستراتيجيه بين طهران وبين
واشنطن وبالتالي هي فقط محاوله لارضاء
اسرائيل
لكن بشكل عام من الصعب جدا قول انه بنتكلم
عن علاقه استراتيجيه جديده او على تحلل
الدفاع جديد حاولت امريكا من قبل ان تقوم
بتشكيل تحالف سنه اسرائيلي في مواجهه
ايران وفشلت في ذلك وقرانا قبل حوالي عام
من الان ان هناك محاوله لوجود نوع من
التنسيق على مستوى الاسلحه الدفاعيه سواء
كان فيما يتعلق باسلحه الصواريخ الجويه او
فيما يتعلق باسلحه بحريه
عن حلف دفاعي هو فقط لارضاء اسرائيل ام ان
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه مصلحه في هكذا
حلف دفاعي مع اسرائيل في المنطقه في
المستقبل القريب باقتضاب لو سمحت
كما قال الدكتور الان هناك اتفاق طويله
المدى فقط مجرد تجديد الاتفاقيات الموجوده
والقائمه اصلا هذا سيستمر لان بواقف قلق
اداره بايدن تقوم على اساس انهم يريدون ان
يكون لديهم نوع من الحضور بالمساواه مع
اداره
نتنياهو وفي الاشهر السته الماضيه اداره
نتنياهو كانت تتجاهل الكثير مما يستر عن
راشد اذا بوجود هذا الاتفاق او هذا
التحالف او الحلف الدفاعي اذا تاسيسه
سيكون هناك شروط تفرض كجزء من الاتفاق
واعتقد ان هذا ما سيقوم به اعضاء مجلس
الامن القومي
من ضمن التحضيرات
للاجتماعات على هامش الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده شكرا لكم جميعا عثر على المقاطعه
شكرا السيد ديفيد في واشنطن الدكتور خليل
عناني في واشنطن ايضا والسيد ايهاب جبارين
في الناصره الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لحسن متابعه
الى اللقاء بامر الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]